bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 12 novembre
[Musique]
rien ne bouge les règles du
déconfinement changer au moins pour les
15 prochains jours déclarations de jean
castex tout à l'heure lors du point
hebdomadaire sur la crise du coc vide
une lueur d'espoir pour les commerçants
un éventuel allègement le 1er décembre
sous couvert de protocole sanitaire
renforcée poursuite de l'apprentissage à
l'école télétravail pas de grandes fêtes
en fin d'année est la vigilance reste de
mise alors que le pic de la deuxième
vague atteindra les hôpitaux la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
aux etats unis la transition au point
mort donald trump refuse toujours de
reconnaître sa défaite à l'élection
présidentielle tandis que joe biden
presse le pas le président élu selon les
projections des médias américains a
nommé ron plein au poste de chef de
cabinet de la maison blanche
un choix qui a suscité les éloges des
démocrates
[Musique]
l'élection de joe biden et ses
conséquences sur le commerce mondial
après le protectionnisme à tous crins
des années trump et la sortie des états
unis de nombreux accords commerciaux
l'arrivée du démocrate à la maison
blanche p'tain calmer le jeu maiden
défenseur du multilatéralisme
il va t'il pour autant inverser la
tendance et renouer avec la chine et
l'europe
autant de questions auxquelles jacques
sapir tentera de répondre tout à l'heure
dans son édito est quoi
[Musique]
il était très attendu le point presse du
premier ministre et ses ministres
concernant la situation sanitaire or que
pouvons-nous que pouvons nous retenir
nous allons tout de suite retrouvé notre
reporter katia pique nique bonsoir katia
pas franchement de grandes annonces de
la part de jean castex et non en effet
le premier ministre a parlé sans
surprise pour lui il serait
irresponsable de lever voire même
d'alléger le dispositif à cause des
chiffres de l'épidémie et à ce sujet je
vous propose de l'écouter
nous comptons ces derniers jours une
hospitalisation toutes les 30 secondes
et une admission en réanimation toutes
les 3 minutes 40 % 40 % des personnes
admises en réanimation ont moins de 65
ans c'est évidemment considérable et
nous avons dépassé en nombre
d'hospitalisations le pic du mois
d'avril
alors même si le nombre des nouvelles
contaminations a baissé de 16% cette
dernière semaine et bien ce n'est pas
encore significatif alors sans surprise
les commerces vont rester fermés et pour
soutenir les commerçants et artisans un
dispositif d un soutien ont été mises en
place alors par exemple jusqu'à 10000
euros du fonds de solidarité ou encore à
un crédit d'impôt pour les bailleurs qui
accepteraient d'offrir le loyer 2
novembre aux commerçants et artisans
alors concernant une possible
réouverture et bien jean castex a évoqué
la date du 1er décembre mais attention
c'est si les chiffres de l'épidémie
était rassurant et encore avec un
protocole sanitaire durci pour
l'éducation jean michel leblanc caire a
annoncé que les lycées qui n'arrivait
pas à respecter 100% des règles
sanitaires pour elle pourrait assurer
jusqu'à 50% de l'enseignement à distance
il y aura aussi davantage de tests pour
le personnel enseignant le personnel des
établissements scolaires
d'ailleurs parlons des tests 1 ils vont
encore être renforcés
le groupe
un homme en a commandé 20 millions de
tests antigénique supplémentaires il y
aura désormais des campagnes de
dépistage dans les entreprises
évidemment au cas par cas les
entreprises qui souhaiteraient le faire
jean castex a également demandé au
ministre au ministère de l'intérieur
d'être ferme concernant le respect de
toutes ces règles du confinement on peut
donc s'attendre à davantage de contrôler
davantage de verbalisation il faut aussi
savoir que même si les commerces
rouvraient au 1er décembre il faudra il
faudra toujours des attestations pour
circuler le déconfinement n'est donc pas
pour tout de suite
merci katia technique et place
maintenant à notre décryptage avec nos
invités et pour en parler nous sommes
avec frédéric jeanjean secrétaire
général de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie des bouches
du rhône merci d'être avec nous très
délicat jeanjean à vos côtés yves
d'amécourt conseiller régional de
nouvelles aquitaine porte parole
national du mouvement de la ruralité de
bonsoir à vous aussi
enfin pour le point de vue médical
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
secrétaire général de la cmf 59/62 merci
d'être avec nous en direct également
bertrand legrand
tout d'abord je m'adresse aux médecins
que vous êtes docteur legrand plutôt
satisfait dans l'ensemble puisque
apparemment rien ne bouge
s'il est fatigué quand rien ne bouge
lorsqu'on voit c'est surtout que le lait
contamination diminue mais on garde bien
à l'esprit que vous mettez en place des
tests anti j'ai maintenant depuis deux
semaines et que donc
le texte rédigé ni par lui même présente
une valeur prédictive négative qui est
moins bonne et que donc on peut avoir de
relâchement de personnes positives et
donc deux fois positif ce qui pourrait
très bien expliqué les missions du
nombre de comptes est ce qu'il va
falloir regarder de près c'est le nombre
de danser à l'hôpital et s'il y avait
une discordance qui apparaît c'est
médiatiquement la réponse donc c'est ça
le plus important je pense et deuxième
message de monsieur verrons nous a pas
encore bien préciser c'est peut-être
antigénique était un test diagnostique -
test de dépistage puisqu'il a utilisé
les deux mousses et toujours très
inquiétant qu'est-ce que vous inquiète
le plus ce porte bien qu'on comprenne
sur ces tests antigénique oliveira a
précisé qu'en cas de positivité les
marges d'erreur était finalement assez
mince c'est négativité justement qu'elle
s'était plus importante c'est ça qui
vous inquiète
c'est exactement ce que c'est un test
qui a une très mauvaise sensibilité et
donc à partir de ce moment là si vous le
faites chez les patients qui ont une
forte prévalence une forte incidence
vous avez maximiser le nombre de faux
négatifs que vous avez relâchement bien
sûr est typiquement quand il me dit qu'
on peut tester avec un restante des
patients symptomatiques de trois à
quatre jours
c'est une erreur fondamentale de thé
senti j'ai été guidé en masse sur des
personnes asymptomatiques
alors que les personnes sans thématique
nécessite un diagnostic par le médecin
donc ça va fort manque de stratégie
comme d'habitude yves d'amécourt
conseiller régional de nouvelles
aquitaine porte parole également
national du mouvement de la ruralité
vous plutôt rassurés par ces annonces de
jean castex soit au contraire plutôt en
colère très en colère parce qu'en fait
on gère la france comme si la france
était paris est donc en fait le virus
circule beaucoup plus dans les zones
urbaines que dans les zones rurales et
les zones rurales sont soumises aux
mêmes
confirmant que les zones urbaines moi
j'espérais que aujourd'hui le premier
ministre allait annoncer que tous les
commerces rouvraient et que pâques par
par contre en serai intransigeant sur
les protocoles de sécurité de 200 t il y
a beaucoup de commerces qui sont
aujourd'hui fermées qui réalise 80 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires dans les deux
derniers mois de l'année notamment les
commerces dits non essentiel puisque en
fait ils sont très spécialisés sur les
fêtes de fin d'année est donc
aujourd'hui on les met en grand danger
on est en grand danger ce qui fait
l'armature de nos zones rurales qui sont
les petits commerces les artisans etc et
on met en danger toute la france parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à raisonner
différemment au premier confinement il y
avait eu un couple préfets maires qui
fonctionnait et qui prenait des
décisions localement en fonction des
enjeux locaux et des spécificités
locales c'est ce qui s'était passé
notamment sur les marchés qui avait été
d'abord fermé puis ré ouvert et en
fonction des saisons et des des lieux
mais là vraiment on raisonne comme si la
france était paris on se bouscule dans
le métro et on interdit tout en france
andrew skull dans les commerces et dans
les rues commerçantes de paris on ferme
tous les commerces en france on va y
revenir évidemment il veut des micros je
vous propose justement d'écouter jean
castex sur la question des commerces
était une des questions les plus
attendus évidemment aujourd'hui en
france notamment pour les commerçants
qui jouent leur survie des premières
mesures d'allégement pourrait intervenir
à compter du 1er décembre mais elle
serait strictement limitée au commerce
que nous avons dû fermer à partir du
confinement et leur réouverture ne
pourrait s'envisager que sur la base
d'un protocole renforcé et frédéric
jeanjean vous vous représentez justement
l'union des métiers des industries de
l'hôtellerie des bouches du rhône
colère que yves d'amécourt il ya quand
même une lueur d'espoir un jean castets
nous parle du 1er décembre sous couvert
de restrictions importantes
il a quand même été dit qu'il était hors
de question il envisageable
les restaurants les bars et les salles
de sport puisse rouvrir ça quand même
été bien entendu je pense que d'une
manière globale il faut se poser de
vraies questions
on ne nie pas la pandémie on nie pas la
problématique ce qui pose problème c'est
la gestion de la pandémie et on a vu
qu'il ya eu une première étape
le premier confinement et depuis il
vient de se rendre compte que en dépit
de tout ce que le gouvernement a pu
raconter dire proposer contredire parce
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de contradictions
aussi au début et bien le virus est
encore là et se développe de plus en
plus donc ce qui pose de gros problèmes
je pense que c'est la méthode nous avons
essayé de proposer des procédures au
gouvernement lorsqu'on est venu fermer
marseille
ils ont proposé un protocole sanitaire
renforcée monsieur verrons a refusé de
nous adresser la parole
finalement ce protocole a été utilisé
pour toute la france je pense que ce qui
pose un problème à l'heure actuelle un
très gros problème c'est ce gouvernement
et sa méthode
c'est le discours de la méthode 10
annoncée des aides je peux vous en
parler de ces aides
ils sont venus annoncer à marseille à la
fin du mois de septembre début du mois
d'octobre pour l'instant on n'a pas vu
la queue d'un radis et les ratings on
les connaît on cuisine on les travaille
souvent donc je peux vous dire que à
l'heure actuelle il ya un mécontentement
qui est fort nous avons fait tout ce que
nous pouvions pour être force de
proposition nous ne pouvons plus être
entendu eh bien nous allons trouver
d'autres moyens pour nous faire entendre
à partir de maintenant
bertrand legrand est ce que vous
comprenez cette colère de nos amis
restaurateurs bar restaurant les empêche
d'ouvrir ils ont fait des efforts
monsieur
jean gens nous disaient voilà encore de
plus en plus finalement deux cas de
contamination alors qu'on a pris des
mesures de plus en plus strictes qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous en tant que
médecin c'est très difficile parce que
je pense qu'ils vont vraiment fortement
ce qu'il faut faire et de voir que on
échoue par défaut de bonnes stratégies
et par défaut de tactique qui les rend
particulièrement en colère et cette
colère mais je l'entends je la comprends
je serai à leur page phréatiques morsure
à la main ferme et ses restaurants et
ses bars pour une si longue durée selon
vous est-ce que c'est là qu'on se
contaminent le plus espéré dire mais par
contre malheureusement si en france on
n'a pas été capable de défier les
endroits à risque ont terminé aux etats
unis ils l'ont fait et on revient que
malheureusement les weiss bars des
restaurants les discothèques les salles
de sport sont des environs se sont
énormément avec un c c'est vraiment un
des sit-in logarithmique donc
malheureusement c'est fois mille fois
fois 2000 phase iii mais c'est froid
c'est effroyable et juste pour vous dire
la 7e ligne après la région après les
offices religieux
c'est les qualités de médecine générale
ou que je devais de vous dire que je
comprends très bien et je comprends très
bien que les protocoles renforcées sont
nécessaires malheureusement on est sur
une zone contient une fréquence
importante de la maladie ces endroits là
ce sont les endroits où on a le plus de
chance d'affronter les médias un espoir
parce que dans cette étude il vient de
montrer que si on diminue le nombre de
personnes présentes dans ses restaurants
on arrive à m aussi exponentiellement à
diminuer la contamination
mais encore une fois il a déconné c'est
pourquoi la stratégie est si mauvaise et
pourquoi la contamination se répand
alors qu'homer maintenant les tests des
masques c'est simplement parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à l'isoler positif on isole
pas les positif et on relâche des faux
négatifs
c'est effroyable mais c'est la
conséquence première c'est qu'on est
obligé de fermer les lieux qui sont des
lieux de contamination
malgré tout
il veut dans mes cours je vous voyez
aucune et du chef
le principal problème est celui là pour
vous aussi la question des tests dans
notre pays il ya deux problèmes le
problème que vient d'exprimer le docteur
c'est comment est-ce qu'on repère les
positif qu'au moins ce qu on les isole
et le deuxième problème c'est l'armement
de l'hôpital pour pouvoir accueillir les
personnes qui ont besoin d'être en
réanimation au mois de juillet le
président de la république promettait
qui aurait 12 mille lits et les legends
formée pour la deuxième vague
en fait je pense qu'il ne croyait pâture
une deuxième vague puisque aujourd'hui
on est assimilé lit et donc on n'est pas
au 2010 promis et donc aujourd'hui on
est en train d'arrêter l'économie d'un
pays parce qu'on n'a pas su armée
l'hôpital parce qu'on n'a pas su faire
des partenariats avec les cliniques
privées qui était prête à rentrer dans
la danse et qui en fait on ont été
boudées au début et donc voilà on n'a
pas à armer nos hôpitaux et le président
a déclaré la guerre est réuni son
conseil de décence mais en fait il n'a
pas pris les mesures qu'on attendait
qu'ils prennent donc mauvaise détection
des positif et non art maintenons un
armement des hôpitaux et c'est nous qui
trinquons partout sur tout le territoire
à propos d'hôpitaux bertrand legrand
jean castex amiens un certain voilà on
tourne bien semé a salué à féliciter les
soignants ça ne vous a pas échappé
défaut peut-être d'augmenter les moyens
concrets à l'hôpital ce que je regrette
c'est que aujourd'hui on est fondée une
théorie qui est le rémunérer pour la
réalisation de tests antigénique qui
sont pas bons et de ne pas rémunérer les
tests pcr
quand ils sont réalisés par les médecins
c'est complètement stupide
on est en train de biaiser la main du
préleveur par un problème financier
c'est le même acte l'un on utilise un
test pour quelqu'un qui est
asymptomatique l'autre pour un test pour
des personnes qui sont symptomatiques le
paiement va être exactement le même pour
le même acte et pour tous les prévenus
et après acte intellectuel
l'analyse et de l'isolément a une valeur
qu'il est forcément supérieurs aux
prélèvements qui est plus rapide
c'était l'heure de stratégie c'est un
pousse au crime et on me paye très cher
dans six semaines
alors il ya eu quelques annonces
peut-être réconfortante sur le point de
vue économique on verra ça avec frédéric
jeanjean dans quelques instants mais
avant je voudrais vous faire justement
écouter bruno le maire concernant les
loyers des commerces
nous mettrons en place dans le budget
un crédit d'impôt de 50% du montant du
loyer abandonné pour tous les bailleurs
qui renonce au loyer du mois de novembre
pour toutes les entreprises qui ont
jusqu'à 250 salariés et qui sont fermés
et j'invite à nouveau par conséquent
tous les bailleurs qui ont signé cet
accord à renoncer à leur loyer du mois
de novembre pour tous les commerces
jusqu'à 250 salariés qui sont fermés un
petit bailleur par exemple qui pour
compléter sa retraite dispose d'un loyer
de 600 euros touchera 300 euros de
crédit d'impôt est locataire lui du coup
n'aura pas à payer son loyer du mois de
novembre cela l'aidera à passer cette
période difficile
après frédéric jeanjean ça c'était
vraiment aussi l'une des requêtes enfin
l'un des soucis et principaux des
commerçants le loyer et charges qui se
poursuivent
la trésorerie est ce que quand même
c'est de manière un petit peu a été
atténué la souffrance des commerçants
selon vous
je pense qu'il faut revenir sur la
question de la méthode quand nous avons
parlé des loyers nous avions mis à
spécifier qu'il y avait trois types de
loyer il ya le loyer qui est dû aux
pouvoirs publics et collectivités
territoriales létale
et là on me demandait l'abandon total il
ya ensuite des grandes foncières qui
établit un loyer à partir d'un
prévisionnel est là il faut revoir le
prévisionnel la baisse est en jeu dès
les particuliers qui louent un bien
immobilier
et là on demandait à ce que ce soit à
leurs prêts qu'on arrive et qu'on leur
enlève de l'heure
leurs impôts un retraité qui arrive dans
c'est l'une des rares sources de revenus
vous pouvez pas lui dire on va nous
enlever la moitié il faut impérativement
qu'on puisse lui dire vous ne vous
n'allez pas souffrir
il y en a pas tant que ça des
propriétaires privés qui des
particuliers qui sont qui sont bailleurs
donc il y a là encore une question de
méthode on essaie de faire du global la
globalisation
tout à l'heure on parlait d'un général
qui partait à l'armée c'est un général
d'opérette ou c'est badinguet quan on va
se retrouver comme la halle à sedan
voilà c'est ce qui nous attend et ça va
être une catastrophe économique une
catastrophe sanitaire une catastrophe
sociale
sachez qu'à l'heure actuelle dans les
bouches-du-rhône où nous en sommes à
notre troisième confinement nous en
sommes à mettre en place des procédures
pour la prévention des suicides chez les
chefs d'entreprise pour les artisans les
tpe les pme et je tiens à rappeler
encore une fois je l' ai déjà dit je
reprises que le printemps arabe en
tunisie a démarré avec un commerçant qui
c'est arrivé qui s'est immolé si jamais
il ya un dérapage on ne pourra plus rien
maîtriser et le gouvernement là ne
pourra pas dire fait dire à qui savaient
pas évidemment comme d'habitude mais par
contre il devra faire face à ses
responsabilités
effectivement chacun ce texte qui a
indiqué que l'activité économique
pourrait baisser de 12% mois de novembre
mais précis si trois fois moins qu'au
printemps dernier elisabeth bornes de la
ministre elle a évoqué les droits à
l'assurance chômage était une
information importante aussi ce soir
écouter comme l'a annoncé le premier
ministre
nous allons donc prolongé de la durée du
confinement les droits à l'assurance
chômage pour les chômeurs arrivant en
fin de droit par exemple un demandeur
d'emploi dont les droits auraient dû
s'éteindre fin novembre continuera à
toucher son allocation chômage au mois
de décembre il d'amécourt ça c'est quand
même une bonne nouvelle vous parlez des
états unis tout à l'heure on sait qu'il
ya beaucoup moins de protection sociale
qui jettent souvent beaucoup de gens
dans la rue il ya au moins ça en france
oui mais il faut ouvrir ça pour tous les
gens dont on vient de parler donc les
indépendants les commerçants les
artisans les auto entrepreneurs tous
ceux dont l'activité est stoppé et qui
eux n'ont pas le droit qui n'ont pas
accès
l'assurance chômage est donc un geste
fort ça aurait été d'ouvrir le droit à
l'assurance chômage pour tous les gens
qu'on empêche de travailler aujourd'hui
et ça c'est pas proposé et donc c'est
quand même terrible ce qui se passe on
est en train de tuer l'économie et on
est en train de penser que la seule vie
qui compte c'est la vie biologique alors
la vie sociale la vie professionnelle la
vie spirituelle toutes ces villas sont
bafoués martyrisé non la vie c'est pas
simplement de manger de boire de rester
chez soi c'est bien plus que ça la vie
et donc il va falloir quand même que ce
gouvernement raisonne différemment
écoute un petit peu plus nos philosophes
comme andré comte sponville qui depuis
trois semaines plaide sur les plateaux
de télévision pour qu'on reconnaisse les
vies de tout de tout le monde ça ça ne
sert à rien de annoncé qu'il ya un
malade de plus toutes les 30 secondes
c'est quoi ce discours ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir si les malades
peuvent être prises en charge
c'est pas savoir s'il ya un malade de
plus toutes les 30 secondes la vérité
c'est que la moyenne d'âge des gens qui
meurent du coc vide est de 81 ans que
l'âge médian est de 84 ans et
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train
d'empêcher des enfants d'aller à l'école
qu'on est en train d'empêcher des
étudiants d'étudier qu'on est en train
d'empêcher des entrepreneurs
d'entreprendre des commerçants de vendre
des artisans de travailler enfin tout ça
est hallucinant il ya soixante dix mille
morts du tabagisme en france chaque
année
est ce qu'on a mis en place une telle
armada de mesure complètement
incohérente pour lutter contre le
tabagisme
enfin si vraiment il ya un enjeu
sanitaire mais il faut passer le paquet
de cigarettes à 60 euros
et puis il faut interdire le tabac il
faut verbaliser les gens qui fument
enfin on est dans quel pays c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe dans notre
pays c'est incroyable bertrand levrat
quand vous entendez
cet argumentaire parce que c'est vrai
que beaucoup de personnes il faut être
honnête pense cela d'ailleurs on va
regarder peut-être un petit sondage
60% des sondés ont déjà transgresser au
moins une fois les règles du confinement
28 % d'entre eux disent avoir un mauvais
moral 38% disent avoir des troubles du
sommeil
c'est vrai que c'est très grave cette
pandémie les chiffres voilà sont
impressionnants est ce que cela vaut
qu'on arrête un pays entier frédéric
jeanjean parler d'éventuels suicide ça
arrivera peut-être on le souhaite pas
mais enfin quelle est l'opinion du
médecin là dessus parce que ça
correspond à la pensée de beaucoup
fraude de france est aussi visée sont
extrêmement en colère
et moi je le comprends je le comprends
parce que cette gestion est un échec à
la fois de la stratégie mis en place à
la fois de la tactique était de frapper
la stratégie est forcé de regarder que
je pense julien régulièrement sur notre
antenne et malheureusement chaque fois
on prévient avance qu' on va d'échec en
échec et derrière la dénonciation
aujourd'hui des problématiques se
détestant tiges et vous verrez que la
prochaine fois on nous emmène en échange
de 500 plus
donc les gens n'en peuvent plus il faut
commencer par corriger nos erreurs avant
de l'amplifier le les mesures
restrictives pour des gens qui ne sont
pas malades
on y mêle pas capable en france d'
isoler correctement les gens malades
peut-être que la privation de liberté et
pour les gens qui sont malades
or c'est avec vous mais je suis désolé
les revend donné il va falloir isoler
les gens avec leurs familles et donc
aujourd'hui il faut isoler le mal isolé
la famille du malade
lorsqu'on va mettre les gens dans des
hôtels ou comme c'était le truc qui lui
est la réalité des choses c'est que
rahman est malade avec certaines moi
quand je me suis pour les tétons je suis
tombé malade je le suivais avec ma
famille c'est comme ça frédéric jeanjean
pour vous ces deux camps finalement on
irait consignables socialement qui
privilégie au maximum la santé ce que
fait aujourd'hui le gouvernement et ceux
qui voudraient privilégiés comme on le
voit donald trump aux états unis
finalement l'économie
je pense pas qu'on puisse opposer les
deux ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de
raisonner et de raisonner sainement ce
qui ne semble pas le cas
c'est à dire que le gouvernement fait
des annonces qui a eu ou des choses
qu'ils écoutent qu'il concerne pas
simplement concertée dans un salon avec
34 personnes qu'il essaye de voir il ya
des prêts faits sur le territoire il ya
des élus locaux
ils peuvent faire les remonter on peut
voir région à région
et quand on s'engage comme ça a été le
cas de la part de monsieur grise et le 7
octobre à marseille à nous dire que nous
aurions de 10000 euros par mois et que
pour l'instant on se rend compte qu on
ouvre à peine les procédures pour qu'on
puisse être indemnisé et qu'on ne verra
ça qu'à partir de la fin du mois de
novembre
c'est se [ __ ] de la gueule du monde
alors ils s'en lavent et leurs
statistiques avec la communication c'est
très bien qu'ils s'amusent entre eux
mais qu'ils sont en train de mettre le
pays
cul par dessus tête quant à monsieur
verrons quand on le sollicite pour lui
proposer le protocole sanitaire
renforcée qui va être appliqué par la
suite dans tout le territoire
ils refusent nous adresser la parole
parce qu'il est qu une boursouflure dgo
et bien ça c'est insupportable de ces
gens là soient en situation de prendre
les décisions
ma dernière question elle concerne l
école puisque c'était attendu par
beaucoup de syndicats qui ont fait une
grève
avant-hier d'ailleurs pour demander
l'extension des mesures de restrictions
renforcées aux collèges et aux primaires
bertrand legrand vous auriez souhaité ça
c'était souhaitable pour vous finalement
le miz blanc caire ne bouge pas les
choses les lycées
sont toujours en force et en termes de
mesures mais pas les collèges les
primaires on est toujours la même chose
au début on pensait que les enfants
étaient peu content et je voulais qu'ils
souhaitent en terre sur la base de ce
que je pouvais voir donc allé dans mon
cabinet puis on s'est rendu compte que s
il était bien content avec elle et bien
des clusters qui se formaient dans les
baies dans les écoles et dans les
collèges et on revient que les clusters
le meilleur royal d'ego mais c'est
extrêmement simple ces beignets et on
est toujours dans ce déni électeurs de
parler glace parce que on nous a parlé
costaud on va dire france ça peut
marcher comme ça c'est pas aussi merci à
tous les trois frédéric jeanjean yves
d'amécourt et bertrand legrand d'avoir
été avec nous en réaction donc aux
annonces ou non annonce d'ailleurs de
jean castex merci à vous restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la présidentielle aux états
unis le bras de fer qui se poursuit
entre donald trump et joe biden d'abord
qu'on doit prendre ses fonctions le 20
janvier joe biden a nommé ron klein au
poste de chef de cabinet de la maison
blanche et puis ce sera les liteaux et
qu on trouvera jacques sapir qui tentera
de répondre à cette question
by dad élus verts une amérique -
protectionnisme ou non
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer que le groupe
énorme comme areva qui est spécialisé
puisse acheter des mines inexploitables
ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire aller à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle créait un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qu'il défendit
il n'y a pas d'alternative au sort du
pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livrant une forme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pg les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on nous parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continuant en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à sugar dépôt les
pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont eu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles
s'esquisse les figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
il est 20h30 heure de paris soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur rt france on se
dirige vers les états unis où des
équipes juridiques de donald trump
disent avoir des preuves d'irrégularités
voire de fraudes liées au scrutin du 3
novembre dernier des accusations
balayées par la plupart des médias et
par le camp démocrate
nous sommes en direct avec notre
reporter thomas bonnet en direct de
washington bonsoir thomas quelles sont
ces éléments dont parle le camp
républicain
et bien la porte parole de la maison
blanche indique détenir 234 pages de
déclaration sous serment établissant des
irrégularités dans un seul compte et du
michigan
il y aurait des bulletins comptés
plusieurs fois encore d'autres qui
porterait la même signature il ya aussi
des lanceurs d'alert qui sont cités dans
un certain nombre de médias américains
notamment une volontaire d'un bureau de
vote dans le nevada qui affirme avoir
constaté elle aussi des irrégularités
sur son lieu de travail alors ces
déclarations sont regroupés par les
équipes juridiques de donald trump est
d'ailleurs le vice gouverneur
républicain du texas offre jusqu'à un
million de dollars en échange de preuve
de l'existence d'une fraude électorale
les équipes de donald trump s'intéresse
également aux logiciels dominion
utilisés dans les urnes électroniques de
certains comtés pour cette élection
roudil rudy giuliani l'avocat de donald
trump indique détenir des témoignages de
salariés de cette entreprise qui fournit
le logiciel dominion attestant de fraude
alors tous ces éléments sont balayés par
les grands médias américains notamment
le new york times qui a publié un
certain nombre d'articles abordant ces
accusations et selon leurs informations
des dizaines d'élus de plusieurs partis
et de plusieurs états indique n'avoir
aucune preuve qu'une fraude
et puis jouer un quelconque rôle dans
l'issue du scrutin deux côtés des
démocrates ont commencé évidemment à
s'impatienter car la transition du
pouvoir est toujours au point mort
elle est la feuille de route du coup de
joe biden
et bien l'ancien vice-président agi en
coulisses pour constituer son
gouvernement il a nommé ce mercredi
ron klein comme futur chef de cabinet
l'idée c'est d'accélérer le processus de
transition en dépit du fait que le
résultat de l'élection n'a toujours pas
été proclamé officiellement joe biden
avait qualifié d' embarrassant le fait
que donald trump ne reconnaissent pas sa
défaite mais dans les rangs des
démocrates
certains se montrent beaucoup moins
patient je propose d'écouter
nous venons d'avoir une élection
présidentielle qui a divisé et qui a été
durement disputé mais au lieu de
rassembler le pays pour que nous
puissions combattre notre ennemi commun
le qu'ovide 19
les républicains du congrès propagent
des théories du complot ni la réalité et
empoisonnent les fondements de notre
démocratie la lutte contre la pandémie
de kobe de 19 et d'ailleurs la priorité
de l'ancien vice président il faut dire
que les chiffres ici sont
particulièrement alarmants pour le
neuvième jour consécutif
plus de cent mille cas ont été détectés
ces dernières 24 heures ce mercredi ce
même ce chiffre a même atteint le record
de 140 mille cas alors a conseillé de
joe biden a affirmé qu un confinement
nationale de quatre à six semaines
pourrait permettre de limiter la
propagation du virus
ici aux etats unis vous risquez d'être
confiné longtemps et de ne pas revenir
en france deux sites aux enchères thomas
merci à vous donc thomas abonnés en
direct de washington et on continue de
parler des états unis de cette
présidentielle avec gerald de ollivier
journaliste en caux américain chercheur
à l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe auteur de sur la route de la
maison blanche aux éditions jean
picollec bonsoir gérald olivier merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on a entendu un autre reporter
thomas parler voilà deux de ses propos
pardon de frôler pas de preuves voulu
dire les deux mais enfin c'est justement
pas la même chose de fraudes massives
sans apporter de preuves
quelles sont les chances justement pour
que donald k donald trump apporte ses
preuves selon vous en fait ils ont des
preuves le problème c'est qu'elle ne
porte pas sur un une quantité de
bulletins probablement suffisante pour
permettre de renverser la donne
très concrètement qu'est-ce qui se passe
les républicains sont en train de
contester le décompte en dans le
wisconsin dans le michigan en
pennsylvanie en géorgie et dans le
nevada ainsi je pense que dans l'arizona
mais la raison en est toujours à compter
donc ils n'ont pas encore de deux procès
ou de poursuites en justice sur place
mais ils ont au minimum je crois c'est
douze mille voix de retard en géorgie
ils ont quarante mille voix de retard en
pennsylvanie ils en ont à peu près
autant dans le michigan
vingt mille environ dans le bus quand
signe ça fait quand même beaucoup de
bulletins ce qui se passe actuellement
c'est qu'ils ont réussi à répertorier un
certain nombre on va pas dire de fraude
mais au moins d'irrégularités dans la
procédure
mais pour l'instant elles portent pardon
sur quelques centaines de cas quoique
milliers de bulletins elle ne porte pas
sur les un nombre suffisant pour
inverser le résultat final dans ses
états c'est ça le problème pour eux
aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya environ cinq
millions de voix d'écart entre les deux
hommes ça fait beaucoup
dans ces conditions on peut se demander
quelle stratégie poursuit donald trump
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent
il cherche à prouver que de toute façon
l'élection lui aura été volé ça c'est
une sorte de point d'honneur pour lui
qu'il gagne ou qu'il ne gagne pas je
pense qu'il est ancré aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit des américains qu'il y a eu un
certain nombre de tricheries notamment
je pense dans l'état de pennsylvanie qui
est le plus pointés du doigt peut-être
le michigan-- également et donc l'idée
pour donald trump c'est de garder
vis-à-vis de sa base ce sentiment que
les démocrates étaient prêts à tout pour
remporter cette élection et qu'ils ont
en effet dans un certain nombre de cas
dépassé les bornes et qu'ils n'ont pas
hésité à procéder à un certain nombre
d'irrégularités et très souvent ce sont
des cas de harcèlement de représentants
républicains plus que des cas de fraude
ouverte mais il y a eu des tricheries un
vote invalides normalement net n'est pas
acceptable
maintenant encore une fois même si
certains des poursuites engagées par
donald trump sont couronnés de succès et
il a remporté une petite victoire encore
aujourd'hui il ya une cour de
pennsylvanie qui a reconnu que certains
bulletins arrivait en retard ne devait
pas être comptés donc de temps en temps
il marque des points
mais encore une fois ce sont des points
qui sont sur d'un décompte marginal et à
terme il est très peu probable qu'il
parvienne à invalider le résultat qui
est celui reporter que par les médias
aujourd'hui qu'elle devrait être à
linverse l'attitude des démocrates mais
également des médias américains des
dirigeants étrangers ce qu'il devrait
dans ce contexte s'abstenir par exemple
de féliciter joe biden ce qu'on devrait
attendre des résultats officiels et la
fin des recours judiciaires
absolument d'un point de vue d'un point
de vue juridique d'un point de vue
strictement légal d'un point de vue
strictement constitutionnel joe biden
n'est pas encore président je rappelle
une évidence les élections
présidentielles américaines se déroule
au suffrage indirect
c'est à dire que le 3 novembre dernier
et lorsque les électeurs américains ont
voté par courrier ils se sont contenté
d'envoyer un mandat à des grands
électeurs
ces grands électeurs se réuniront le 14
décembre le 14 décembre sera la date qui
officialisera le résultat et d'ici au 14
décembre
on s'attend à ce que toutes les
poursuites n'ont pas soit arrêté ou
suspendus mais qu'elle ait trouvé une
conclusion pour que le résultat a
indiqué par chaque état soit
incontestable est la preuve que le
président le président élu joe biden
n'est pas encore techniquement
présidence et que la constitution ne lui
applique pas encore les droits d'un
président élu et cela ne commencera qu'à
partir du 14 décembre après le vote du
fameux collège électoral donc d'ici là
les démocrates devraient faire preuve de
patience je pense qu'il devrait au
contraire même coopérer avec les
républicains pour chercher à faire toute
la lumière et rétablir une confiance de
l'électorat envers leurs institutions
quant aux dirigeants étrangers et
d'ailleurs certains l'ont bien compris
ils devraient s'abstenir je rappelle que
la chine et je pense là la russie à ce
jour n'ont pas encore officiellement
félicité joe biden ou kamala harris
en tout cas c'est pas ce qui se passe
parce que joe biden lui est en train de
monter son son équipe en il a nommé chef
de cabinet ron klein savez quoi
d'ailleurs on en sait déjà beaucoup sur
cet homme ça semble saluer en tout cas
cette nomination par les démocrates
ron klein c'est un ancien de l'équipe
byden c'était son chief of staff son
chef de cabinet lorsqu'il était
vice-président est au tour de joe biden
on a surtout vu des gens qui ont
appartenu ou travailler avec l'équipe
obama et qui sont des fonctionnaires
assez chevronnés du département d'état
où d'ailleurs je pense à madame green
fils par exemple pour l'instant on a une
équipe obama bis qui se met en place
maintenant il est parfaitement naturel
que joe biden souhaite préparer et
mettre en place sa transition
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de contestation
lorsque le résultat est acceptée par
tout le monde
eh bien on peut commencer à travailler
avant que le collège électoral
n'officialise le résultat cette année
est un petit peu particulière parce que
d'une part le résultat est très serré
pas forcément
en ce qui concerne le vote populaire
mais au moins en ce qui concerne le
collège électoral
et comme il y à des contestations eh
bien il est logique que l'équipe de
transition attendent maintenant si joe
biden veut prendre les devants il peut
le faire mais techniquement légalement
juridiquement il ne sera pas élu avant
le 14 décembre
merci gérald ollivier journaliste franco
américain chercheur à l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et depuis la victoire annoncée de
joe biden face à donald trump les etats
unis sont en pleine période
transition une transition délicate
puisque donald trump n'a pas reconnu sa
défaite on vient de le dire
que se passe-t-il ces quelques mois qui
précède le jour j où le président élu
doit prêter serment il y at il déjà eu
des frictions comparable dans le passé
éléments de réponse en images
[Musique]
où
en
[Musique]
et
l'élection de joe biden et ses
conséquences sur le commerce mondial
après le protectionnisme à tous crins
des années trump et la sortie des états
unis de nombreux accords commerciaux
l'arrivée du démocrate à la maison
blanche peut-elle calmer le jeu bay
d'annoncé est un tenant du
multilatéralisme mais va-t-il pour
autant inverser la tendance et renouer
avec la chine et l'europe
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bienvenus
chaque jour stéphanie bonsoir jacques
alors l'élection américaine peut-elle
apporter un changement majeur dans la
politique commerciale des etats unis
beaucoup se posent la question en tout
cas oui effectivement c'est fini on sait
que donne un train pavés et
spectaculairement rompu certains accords
commerciaux etc il s'affirmait
ouvertement protectionnistes alors son
successeur probable je dis bien probable
car les résultats de l'élection de
seront néanmoins définitif que le 14
décembre comme un 10-1 précédent invités
et bien un son successeur probable
amènera avec lui certainement un
changement de style peut penser que la
politique du tweet ravageur est sans
doute terminée mais si on regarde la
politique commerciale des etats-unis on
peut douter en fait que sur le fond il y
ait une si grande différence
alors jacques doit-on s'attendre à ce
que les états unis reviennent au libre
échange
non non c'est fanny et pour une très
bonne raison
les etats-unis ont toujours été un pays
très protectionniste et ceci en dépit
d'un discours à par an en faveur du
libre-échange
vous savez ce que me disait d'ailleurs
mais mes professeurs il ya fort
longtemps dans la politique américaine
le libre échange c'est un produit
d'exportation pas un produit de
consommation intérieure alors jacques la
politique de donald trump avait quand
même pourtant bien signifier un tournant
protectionnistes mais en fait c'est fini
ce que l'on a retenu de sa politique
c'est essentiellement la sortie de ces
grands accords commerciaux
de fait et si vous voulez on peut le
voir justement sur ce graphique qui est
réel
et par l'organisation mondiale du
commerce et bien en fait les états unis
n'ont pas cessé depuis des années de
prendre des mesures protectionnistes
on voit par exemple que dans les deux
dernières années du mandat de barack
obama
il ya eu un très grand nombre de ces
mesures protectionnistes
ainsi de 2009 à 2016
il ya aussi de nombreuses mesures qui
ont été prises pour des motifs dits
phytosanitaires mais qui ont en réalité
servi à bloquer un certain nombre
d'importations agricole alors pour vos
jacques dans notre homme se situerait
dans la continuité de la politique
commerciale américaine
oui oui effectivement bien sûr les
méthodes qui l'employait pas ça décoiffe
et un peu ça c'est très clair
mais sur le fond sa politique elle était
beaucoup plus dans la continuité que
dans la rupture savez on comptait au
mois de juin 2020 pas moins de 526
mesure faisant obstacle au commerce
international en vigueur aux états unis
c'est un nombre considérable et sur ses
526 mesure il faut savoir que les trois
quarts étaient antérieurs à donald trump
et pourtant ce dernier avait
spécifiquement suivez la chine faut-il
s'attendre à ce que joe biden change de
politique
non non non là encore non c'est fini
parce que cette politique d'affrontement
économique et technologique il faut le
rappeler avec la chine fait l'objet d'un
profond accord entre les démocrates et
les républicains aux états unis cette
politique
en réalité c'est ce qu'on appelle
typiquement une politique bipartisane
alors il n'y a pas de raison qu'elle
change bien sûr un job hayden y mettra
des formes que donald trump n'y aurait
pas misé mais l'orientation générale de
cette politique restera inchangé et le
fait que le sénat des états unis qui va
rester on le sait maintenant aux mains
des républicains sera toujours mais
justement un sénat républicain devrait
beaucoup faire pour la continuité de
cette politique
et en ce qui concerne ce qui nous
intéresse particulièrement l'union
européenne alors oui effectivement un
job à raiden affirmé
soutenir et aimer l'europe seulement il
nous faudra apprendre à distinguer les
mots et les actes
en effet là encore il ya un profond
d'accord au sein de l'élite américaine
cette dernière considère ainsi que
l'allemagne est un ennemi commercial
pratiquement au même titre que la chine
de même les états unis s'opposeront
aussi à la france sur le dossier boeing
airbus et elle ne reculera devant rien
pour sauvegarder la position prééminente
de boeing ou de là rien ne montre que
les etats unis soient prêts justement à
renoncer à leur mesure dite extra
territorial qui pénalise lourdement en
priorité des entreprises européennes
alors quelles sont les mesures
auxquelles vous faites référence
ces mesures paradoxalement elles ont été
prises sous la présidence de barack
obama qui était pourtant considéré comme
un président très favorable au
multilatéralisme et à la mondialisation
il s'agit de deux choses tout d'abord
rien le foreign corrupt practices act
qui pue d'idées des actes de corruption
et pierre lefort tax act qui s'assure
que vous êtes bien en accord avec la loi
fiscale américaine
mais ces mesures autorisant réalité les
états les états unis à pénaliser des
sociétés étrangères si elles
n'appliquent pas des décisions
américaines alors qu'elle ne travaille
pas sur le sol américain
par exemple le foreign account tax
compliance act a été considérablement
aggravée par une décision des autorités
américaines
celle de considérer que tout usage du
dollar entre deux sociétés
même si ces deux sociétés ne sont pas
sur le sol des états unis même si elles
ne dépendent pas des états dits et bien
que cette puce 1 du dollar faisait
automatiquement tomber ces deux sociétés
sous le coup de la loi américaine
alors des sociétés françaises par
exemple alstom
technip et puis des banques aussi comme
bnp paribas le crédit agricole ou la
société générale ont été condamnés et
ont été condamnés
demain du fait de ces procédures donc en
clair vous n'attendez pas grand chose
finalement de joe biden non absolument
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est fini
le nouveau président continuera la
politique de son prédécesseur
ce dernier avait en réalité continuer
voire jédir et aggraver un la politique
de son propre prédécesseur la priorité
donnée par les états unis à
l'affirmation unilatérale de leurs
intérêts cela tiendra peut-être que joe
barton il mettra des formes mais
peut-être pas de même la priorité donnée
aux relations avec la chine
une priorité qui date en fait de barack
obama va se maintenir
enfin les états unis continueront de
vouloir que les pays européens ne soient
que des consommateurs ward et sous
traitants mais certainement pas des
acteurs importants du commerce
international des producteurs importants
de biens cruciaux comme je vous le
disais en introduction pour les états
unis
le libre échange c'est un produit
d'exportation et certainement pas un
produit de consommation intérieure merci
jacques nous avoir fait réfléchir la
continuité sans le changement donc merci
a vous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la
conférence de presse de jean castex les
règles du confinement qui restent
inchangées pour au moins 15 jours
et puis nous parlerons du professeur
didier rahout le fervent défenseur de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine qui est
poursuivi par l'ordre des médecins
on
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire à des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident
c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fismes
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
monsieur l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france on parle de
l'afrique comme d'un continent en
perpétuel devenir son dysfonctionnement
actuel tient à l'absence de
redistribution à la population par des
dirigeants qui ont une fâcheuse tendance
à tout garder pour les pays occidentaux
ont favorisé cette dérive en
encourageant le maintien au pouvoir de
politiciens de plus en plus âgés pour
assurer la stabilité des pays et des
sous régions elles ont eu la prétention
de croire que les valeurs qu'elle défend
des est imposé par la force dans leur
conquête était universel dans cette
terre des possibles s'esquisse les
figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa va entraîner qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
à
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on s'en doutait il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture et puis les
espaces naturels c'est grâce à la chasse
grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez l'un trois ans vous êtes une
femme qu'est ce que vous espérez
apporter justement à ce monde de la
chasse si je peux aider avec avec ce que
je fais sur les réseaux sociaux expira a
montré un autre aspect de la chasse et à
donner envie à certaines personnes de la
découvrir
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé
donnait le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
au loin de paris mais toujours loin de
ceux qui les dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on les passe un
tour de tracteur avec nous puis la
campagne il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bach fauré td quoi un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
21h01 française merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'information
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 12 novembre
rien de bouge les règles du confinement
inchangés au moins pour les 15 prochains
jours déclarations de jean castex tout
est la leur lors du point sur la crise
du coc vide
une lueur d'espoir pour les commerçants
louve en tuer l'allègement le premier
descend sous couvert de protocole
sanitaire renforcée poursuite de
l'apprentissage à l'école télétravail
pas de grandes fêtes de fin d'année la
vigilance reste de mise alors que le pic
de la deuxième vague attendra les
hôpitaux la semaine prochaine cela fera
cinq ans demain que la france a été
frappée par une vague d'attentats des
commandos de génie seront 130 morts et
350 blessés à l'extérieur du stade de
france près de paris
et sur des terrains sur la capitale et
dans les salles de spectacle du bataclan
des commémorations alors que la france
ait été l'objet d' attaques ces
dernières semaines encore le parlement
de hong kong au tiers vides seules les
parlementaires favorables à pékin
continue siégé hier l'ensemble des
députés anti gouvernementaux du conseil
législatif qui ont annoncé leur
démission en raison du renvoi de quatre
de leurs collègues sur une décision
pékin l'union européenne appelle à leur
réintégration immédiate
[Musique]
il était très attendu le point presse du
premier ministre concernant la situation
sanitaire alors que pouvons-nous en
retenir en fait le point avec notre
reporter katia technique
alors même si le nombre des nouvelles
contaminations a baissé de 16% cette
dernière semaine et bien ce n'est pas
encore significatif alors sans surprise
les commerces vont rester fermés et pour
soutenir les commerçants et artisans un
dispositif d'aidé un soutien ont été
mises en place alors par exemple jusqu'à
10000 euros du fonds de solidarité ou
encore à un crédit d'impôt pour les
bailleurs qui accepteraient d'offrir le
loyer 2 novembre aux commerçants et
artisans alors concernant une possible
réouverture et bien jean castex a évoqué
la date du 1er décembre mais attention
c'est si les chiffres de l'épidémie
était rassurant et encore avec un
protocole sanitaire durci pour
l'éducation jean michel leblanc caire a
annoncé que les lycées qui n'arrivait
pas à respecter 100% des règles
sanitaires pourraient ils pourraient
assurer jusqu'à 50% de l'enseignement à
distance il y aura aussi davantage de
tests pour le personnel enseignant le
personnel des établissements scolaires
d'ailleurs parlons des tests 1 ils vont
encore être renforcés
le gouvernement a commandé 20 millions
de tests antigénique supplémentaires il
y aura désormais des campagnes de
dépistage dans les entreprises
évidemment au cas par cas les
entreprises qui souhaiteraient le faire
jean castex a également demandé au
ministre au ministère de l'intérieur
d'être ferme concernant le respect de
toutes ces règles du confinement on peut
donc s'attendre à davantage de contrôler
davantage de verbalisation il faut aussi
savoir que même si les commerces
rouvraient au 1er décembre il faudra il
faudra toujours des attestations pour
circuler le déconfinement n'est donc pas
pour tout de suite les règles restent
inchangées et donc pendant au moins 15
jours écoutez les réactions recueillies
dans les rues de paris
je pense qu'on va continuer comme les
quinze premiers jours se sont déjà
déroulées
pour ma part je
suit en confinement mais pas en 100%
confinement à
donc voilà donc on attend des quinze
premiers jours et c'est vrai qu'on
aimerait qu'on attend tous plus de
visibilité et savoir comment est ce
qu'on peut se projeter pour ses fameuses
fêtes de noël
est ce qu'on va pouvoir les passer en
famille où est ce qu'on va pouvoir
rester entre nous je pense que c'est
nécessaire de faire ce confinement
après est ce qu'il est juste pour tout
le monde évidemment je ne suis pas
certain
il ya des petits commerçants je pense
aux coiffeurs oppose indépendant ça va
être compliqué il n'ya pas d'autre choix
au final quand on a pas d'autre solution
que d'être confiné si on veut que mettre
terme à la crise
donc je pense que pas un n'a pas d'autre
choix en fait on peut on doit l'accepter
ou la vraie préoccupation sont tous les
commerces qui sont fragilisés et tous
les métiers tous les postes qui vont
être impactés
voilà qu'est ce qui se profile couru
après c'est la véritable interrogation
si cette épidémie doit perdurer et
fonctionner par par différents épisodes
quentin différentes vagues est les
derniers chiffres du coronavirus en
france santé publique france dénombre 33
mille cent soixante douze nouveaux cas
de contamination kovy dans 24heures 418
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital et
386 passion été admis en réanimation le
taux de positivité des tests s'établit
désormais à 18 7% les nouveaux décès
porte le bilan total des morts dus
qu'aux vide en france à 42 1960 il s'est
illustré dans cette lutte contre le
commis 19 contesté au sein du monde
médical didier raoul tu va à nouveau
devoir faire face aux critiques de ses
pairs le directeur de l'inf europol de
marseille va comparaître devant les
instances disciplinaires de l'ordre des
médecins le grand promoteur de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine se retrouve une
nouvelle fois dans la tourmente quentin
mauclair controversé depuis qu'a
commencé la crise sanitaire
le professeur de médecine marseillais
didier rahout va devoir s'expliquer
devant les instances disciplinaires de
l'ordre des médecins
cette convocation dévoilé ce jeudi par
le conseil national de l'ordre des
médecins découle d'une plainte déposée
en juillet dernier par la société de
pathologie infectieuse de langue
française
d'après le magazine paris match l'as
cliff reproche au médecin d'avoir
utilisé des traitements non validé ainsi
que d'avoir manqué aux devoirs de
confraternité didier rahout avait
également fait l'objet de plusieurs
signalements de patients mais aussi
d'autres médecins va arrêter
d'être dans les débats scientifiques au
et kiko politico médiatique on va
arrêter d'être dans la vindicte
populaire
en tout cas de cette frange marginale de
la profession pourrait être sur le
terrain rigoureux du droit et sur le
terrain du droit dit raúl est
effectivement n'a absolument rien à
craindre de deux voilà de l'ordre des
médecins n'a rien à craindre
effectivement de cette comparution
vaches en tipi nerfs je le redis il a
hâte en ce que il entend effectivement
s'expliquer précisément et sortira de là
avec son honneur lavé la question qu'on
peut raisonnablement se poser en
sera-t-il de même pour les institutions
ordinales ou alors est-ce qu'elles ne
seront pas ridiculiser mi-septembre le
microbiologiste avait déjà été entendu
par la commission d' enquête du sénat
seul face aux sénateurs ils avaient
défendu son traitement à l'hydroxyethyl
rockin contre le nouveau corner virus
lui qui mène depuis plusieurs mois des
essais cliniques avec cette molécule
toutefois l'efficacité de ce remède
contre le coc u19 n'a pas été établie
c'est pas moi qui développe l'enquêté je
les dis encore la semaine dernière
donc c'est pas moi qui développe
l'anxiété donc le l'interdiction de
prier ce qu'hier tout le monde c'est mon
opinion dessus si vous voulez mais là
encore je vois pas comment on aurait pu
avoir un débat serein quand en espace de
2 d'une demi journée
on sait le ministère et l'om et s'est
mis à dire on interdit partout hydroxy
chloroquine parce que ça tue les gens
pour un papier qui a été retiré trois
semaines après parce que c'était une
bande de pieds nickelés qui avait écrit
ce truc dont personne ne savait d'où il
sortait donc c'est à moi qui raconte des
bêtises grève ça au bout d'un moment il
faut revenir sur terre c'est pas moi car
quand la bêtise accusé de plusieurs
entorses à la déontologie didia août
aura le temps de se préparer avant
d'être auditionné par ses pairs d'après
le conseil national de l'ordre des
médecins
le délai de traitement de ce type de
plainte est en moyenne de 10 mois
tantôt adulé tantôt critique et didier
raoul n'en finit donc pas de faire
parler de lui mais le professeur devra
cette fois ci se défendre face à ses
pairs alors est il allé trop loin dans
la défense de son traitement at il
enfreint le code de déontologie médicale
ou cherchons au contraire à le faire
taire place à notre décryptage avec nos
invités
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec violaine guérin médecin
endocrinologue vous êtes membre du
collectif laissons les médecins à
prescrire bonsoir violaine guerra merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous à vos côtés
bruno m'égare ban chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bon soir bruno me garbade merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
le conseil de lantier donc décidé de
poursuivre didier rahout c'est tout de
même une procédure disciplinaire c'est
pas rien violaine des reins
c'est une procédure disciplinaire mais
en fonction de l'article 5 du code de
déontologie article r 41 35 5 du code de
santé publique
nul ne peut aliéner la dépendance
professionnels d'un médecin donc
monsieur raoult tafer des communications
sur des recherches qu'il a fait je vois
difficilement le conseil de l'ordre
pouvoir le condamner à ce sujet et
j'ajoute même que du moment où son
action n'a occasionné aucun dommage et
que au contraire
l'abstention est responsable d'une perte
de chance ce n'est peut-être pas le
professeur raoul tki qui va être embêté
par cette procédure mais ceux qui
prétendent l'empêcher d'agir
et contrairement à ce qui a été dit dans
votre documentaire il y a énormément de
publication au niveau mondial qui ont
montré qu'en phase précoce de traitement
les associations et donc six clans qui
nazis trop missiles étaient non
seulement bien toléré mais également
avait apporté des bénéfices aux
personnes qui avaient été traitées ainsi
et je peux d'autant plus en témoigner
que nous mêmes le collectif laissons les
médecins prescriront travailler avec les
médecins qui étaient malades pour mois
de mars
février mars avril puisqu'il y avait
beaucoup de médecins généralistes qui
était malade et qui ont souhaité suivre
ce protocole et nous avons publié
également ces données au niveau 1
nationale donc c'est très important
d'être très vigilants aussi sur ce que
vous dites dans vos reportages parce
qu'il y a ce qui s'est passé on va dire
en ville ou en traitement de phase
précoce et puis ce qui s'est passé
également dans les réanimations à des
stades beaucoup plus tardif et on sait
très bien que ce sont des stades de la
maladie qu'ils sont différents donc il
faut être extrêmement vigilant sur ce
que l'on dit c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi
de nombreux responsables français
notamment politiques qui sont exprimés
dans de nombreux médias en
décrédibilisant ce traitement hydroxyque
l'europe qui nous avait bien raison
parce que c'était précisément ma
prochaine question j'ai pris la peine
d'aller regarder avant cette émission la
carte des pays qui recommandait hydroxy
chloroquine et c'est assez
impressionnant la carte se colore avec
plein de pays pas les moindres la moitié
des etats-unis les pays-bas l'iran la
chine le maroc la tunisie
j'en passe la russie qui recommandait
qui utilisent justement cette molécule
alors qu'on semble diaboliser le
professeur raoul qu'en france parce que
précisément ils utilisent bruno m'égare
balle ça vous inspire quoi justement
vous en tant que médecin pourquoi des
pays à l'est moins quand même pas les
plus sous-développées utilisent cette
molécule est le professeur out est
diabolisé pour cela dans notre pays
alors tout d'abord je ne crois pas que
l'essentiel des plaintes qui ont été
formulées auprès de l'ordre des médecins
concerne l'utilisation de la lide roxy
chloroquine je crois que effectivement
le processeur out a une intuition
extrêmement sens et au départ basé
d'ailleurs sur des travaux qu'il a fait
lui même sur l'efficacité in vitro de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine pour stopper la
réplication virale et ensuite
effectivement basé sur son expérience
très large et reconnu internationalement
comme infectiologues
il a souhaité utiliser ce traitement
chez les patients qui présentaient
lakovic 19 à un moment où bien sûr on
n'avait pas d'autre thérapeutique
d'autres alternatives thérapeutiques
donc on va dire sa démarche scientifique
initiale était tout à fait louable
après ce que ce qui lui a été reprochée
c'est de persister dans l'affirmation
que les drogues cyclo au quine et
efficace alors qu'effectivement ça
cumulé un certain nombre d'arguments
scientifiques qui on va dire démontrez
l' inverse
malgré tout je ne crois pas que à
nouveau que ça soit le sujet de la
plainte de l'ordre des médecins je crois
chaque médecin a le droit de dire que
tel traitement efficace ou tel autre ne
l'est pas en fonction de son expérience
personnelle je crois qu essentiellement
on l'appela la plainte porte sur des
histoires de violation de confraternité
et d'éventuellement d'informations
erronées du public
mais pour ma part plutôt sur le on va
dire l'absence de dangerosité de la
corona virus qui pourrait plus posé on
va dire question on faire je confirme à
décridibiliser d'une certaine manière le
professeur raoul qu'est-ce qu'on on le
poursuit aussi pour charlatanisme sais
c'est pas rien quand même pour un
professeur de médecine
vérane guérin pour vous c'est finalement
la personnalité du dr raul qui est en
jeu où on règle ses comptes entre
médecins finalement puisque bruno
megaman le le rappeler c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu des mots envers les confrères pas
toujours très gentil c'est sûr on va
déjà aussi dire qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
mots très désagréable vis-à-vis de
monsieur raoul tu et que les médecins
qui ont proféré ces mots n'ont même pas
été inquiété du tout parce que c'était
2-2 très agressif et même très incorrect
moi ce que je vais dire c'est que
monsieur raoult est bon a fait ses
recherches effectivement une vitre à moi
en tant que médecin quand j'ai dû
m'occuper de mes confrères bon bien
entendu j'ai entendu monsieur raoul
préconise faire des préconisations mais
ce que j'ai fait surtout jeu près toute
la littérature chinoise
j'ai repris aussi la littérature du ca
d'un épisode du strass du phare score
1-1 et j'ai bien
noté l'intérêt des chinois he que ce
soit pour la chloroquine pour les
drogues cyclone qui les avaient traités
avec différentes molécules et c'est en
reprenant cette bibliographie là que je
me suis fait mon idée aussi et que j'ai
essayé et aussi les recommandations du
professeur raoul puisqu'elle faisait
sens quand on avait repris toute la
bibliographie dussart score 1 et y
compris de la la manière dont la
pathologie
le strass se présentait et on avait déjà
énormément d'informations finalement par
rapport à ce type de deux pathologies
virales et des atteintes pulmonaires
donc dire que monsieur raoult peut-être
un charlatan autre bon de toutes ces
choses n'ont strictement aucun sens et
ce qui est très inquiétant c'est que
c'est tout à fait anormal ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est normal parce
que on pourra voir moi publié beaucoup
dans le passé on peut ne pas être
d'accord entre confrères on discute on
va des congrès on échange mais on n'est
pas dans un niveau de violence tel qu'on
l'a vue actuellement et dans des niveaux
de d'anomalies sur les publications le
lundi 7 guette des choses comme ça c'est
du jamais vu mais enfin bon moi j'ai 60
ans vendent donc j'ai publié quand
j'étais beaucoup plus jeune et à un
moment où il y avait sans doute beaucoup
moins de conflits d'intérêt partout et
ce qui aujourd'hui la crise
elle révèle justement des conflits
d'intérêts elle révèle des querelles
elle révèle des historiques aussi de
querelles un peut-être mais moi je suis
navré parce qu'on en oublie les patients
dans tout ça et ça augmente beaucoup
l'angoissent des gens même les médecins
sont perdus les médecins reçoivent des
injonctions
la rs de la direction générale de la
santé par rapport aux prescriptions mais
c'est ça aussi c'est du jamais vu
les médecins généralistes aujourd'hui
qu'ils reçoivent en ville des
interdictions de prescrire de l'asie
trop missiles sur des baies pathologies
des surinfections pulmonaires ou des
pathologies pulmonaires ont des tableaux
de présentation pulmonaire alors que
cette classe de médicaments les
macrolides est vraiment une place
intéressante pour traiter des patients
aujourd'hui les médecins généralistes
ont encore reçu des messages comme quoi
fallait encourager la télémédecine
mais ça c'est du grand n'importe quoi on
les patients on les examine en les
ausculte pourquoi il ya eu beaucoup de
morts parce qu'il ya aussi des gens
qu'on n'a pas examiné qu'on a laissé
continuer de se dégrader chez eux
et là on a changé complètement les
circuits habituels du soin ce qui n'est
pas du tout normal
en tout cas la principale critique et
vous aujourd'hui de l'avocat en lui même
des vidéos à ault m fabrice division
très remonté contre le conseil de
l'ordre des médecins ont l'écoutent
l'ordre n'a rien fait depuis le début il
ya des médecins qui sont morts
café l'ordre rien les médecins manquent
et de masques et de ffp2 café l'ordre
rien mais que fait l'ordre il n'a
poursuivi que les médecins qui ont
utilisé de l'hydroxyde chloroquine est
ce que l'ordre a réagi aurait me désire
non un prénommé garvan à votre réaction
mais écoutez je trouve qu'on mélange
beaucoup de choses je vois pas quel est
le rapport entre l'hydroxyde chloroquine
les masques et le remdh et sévir donc
effectivement l'hydroxyde chloroquine a
été promu au départ par monsieur raoul
départ d'autres moi même je l' ai
prescrit à une cinquantaine de patients
lors du premier pic épidémique nous nous
sommes rendu compte au travers de nos
observations mais également au travers
d'études randomisées que malheureusement
ça ne marchait pas on aurait tous
souhaité évidemment que ce soit
parfaitement efficace et donc on a
arrêté de le prescrire maintenant
évidemment je suis d'accord avec ma
consoeur moi je n'aurais pas je n'aurai
pas
promu une interdiction par les autorités
sanitaires
j'aurais plutôt préféré des
recommandations de bon usage
on voit bien effectivement que cette
affaire a tourné un peu à la folie
quelque part et là on mélange avec leur
mdc dire qui n'a rien à voir quelqu'un
autre traitement antiviral qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas davantage montré
d'efficacité plus probante
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui nous ne le
prescrive on pas y compris pour les
patients les plus graves en réanimation
parce que très probablement son
efficacité versus série ce que n'est pas
très favorable donc c'est pas parce que
l'on prescrit pas que l'on n'adhère pas
à l'idée que l'hydroxyde chloroquine est
efficace que l'on ait nécessairement un
suppôt du laboratoire gilead qui promeut
et qui vend le rêve des civils pour ma
part je suis totalement neutre je
regarde uniquement les arguments
scientifiques mais aujourd'hui je le
prescrit ni l'hydroxyde chloroquine ni
leur md sévir al'inverse les masques
peut-on parfaitement prouvées un intérêt
préventif et donc je porte le masque
soignants tous les jours des tas de
patients infectés par l'aco vide je peux
vous rassurer je ne vais pas attraper
grâce à ses moyens de prévention en cage
entre et vous fait réentendre un didier
rahout principal sujet de conversation
c'était le 30 avril dernier lors de la
première vague et déjà ses prises de
paroles agacé écouter ce que nous irons
pense je peux dire ce que je fais j'ai
bien droit le dire j'ai le droit de
m'exprimer scientifiquement les
universitaires ont une liberté de parole
qui est inscrite dans la constitution
personne ne peut toucher ça et la
question est est ce qu'il ya vraiment
une liberté de parole pour les
scientifiques avionnais nogueira écouter
théoriquement une liberté de parole un
mois je la prends aussi et je confirme
que j'ai traité des patients avec ce
protocole et en particulier des médecins
et que ça s'est bien passé en phase
précoce à la différence de mon confrère
monsieur mes gars ban
moi je suis en ville donc je vois les
patients tôt et monsieur mes gars banal
une expérience en réanimation qui sont
des expériences totalement différente et
je l'entends bien quand il dit que son
expérience n'est pas positiver et je
veux bien croire
simplement on n'a pas vu les patients au
même stade donc ça c'est extrêmement
important d'en avoir conscience
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est que
quand même quand on voit des personnes
qui sont des scientifiques et qui ne qui
attaquent des de façon tout à fait
irrationnel des publications c'est tout
à fait anormal et vous avez rappelé le
nombre de pays qui traite et anecdotes
j'étais il ya quelques jours avec un
médecin franco marocain et qui exercent
en france et qui me disait mais au début
de la crise mes collègues du maroc map
l'aiment pour dire mais qu'est ce que
vous fichez en france
nous on traite avec les toxiques la
rouquine tout se passe très bien et bon
vous savez que le roi du maroc a aussi
présenté les loaded roxy chloroquine et
le pays gère à gérer la crise
remarquablement bien comme ça et c'est
pas le seul pays en italie les les
médecins sont en train de réutiliser sur
cette deuxième phase d'épidémie
saisonnières le cette deuxième
l'épidémie saisonnière c'est pas une
deuxième vague comme on veut bien dire
mais sont des épidémies saisonnières qui
repartent et les italiens sont en train
d'utiliser cette molécule
donc c'est important de
de comprendre d'essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe parce qu'on est dans
quelque chose d'irrationnel aujourd'hui
dans ces vallées jour je la fais un
bruno mégarde vannes justement c'est un
petit peu contre produits puis cette
communication à nouveau lancée autour du
professeur raoul qui a déjà une grosse
défiance des français envers les
autorités
oui très probablement et c'est pourquoi
c'est toutes ces démarches mon avis sont
peut-être dommageable à terme
je crois que manning manifestement il ya
des plaintes il ya un certain nombre de
personnes notamment la société française
de pathologie infectieuse qui a formulé
des plaintes
donc c'est à la justice et notamment la
justice ordinale de se prononcer donc je
ne me substituerait pas aux médecins qui
font partie de cette chambre
disciplinaire
alors c'est vrai que le procès raout
encourent des sanctions personnellement
je ne crois pas qu'on en arrive à ce
stade là c'est je trouve de tout ça
dommageable malgré tout je suis d'accord
effectivement les enseignants doivent
jouir d'une indépendance et d'une
entière liberté d'expression dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions néanmoins
évidemment tout ça doit se faire dans le
respect strict des principes de
tolérance et d'objectivité et donc à
l'ordre de médecins de formuler si
effectivement tout ce qu'a affirmé le
professeur raoul était totalement
objectif est basé sur les des arguments
scientifiques
merci à vous bruno megaman merci
également à vous violaine l'erreur
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france le coronavirus toujours avec une
annonce de freezer avec la compagnie el
banques allemandes bio ntech sur
l'efficacité et 90% de son vaccin et a
suscité une vague d'enthousiasmé à
travers le monde
enthousiasme qui n'a pas échappé aux
marchés financiers est d'ailleurs le pdg
13h a vendu lundi pour 5,6 millions de
dollars soit 4 76 millions d'euros
d'actions du laboratoire américain le
jour même de l'annoncé par le groupe de
bons résultats préliminaires sur un
vaccin
l'action s'était envolée de plus de 7%
interrogé par cnn un porte-parole de la
direction du labo assuré que ces
transactions étaient déjà prévus dans un
plan de désinvestissements périodiques
mis en place par le patron du groupe
lorsque le titre atteint un certain prix
et la crise sanitaire dont le reste de
l'europe l'espagne a passé le seuil des
40 mille décès liés aux kobe 19 depuis
le tout début de l'épidémie mais le
gouvernement se montre optimiste et sûr
déjà entrevoir une tendance à la baisse
l'exécutif continue d'écarter l'idée
d'un confinement total à domicile les
précisions de leslie singh la
journaliste indépendante
les restrictions mises en place au cours
de ces dernières semaines semblent
porter leurs fruits
les chiffres sont plutôt positives pour
les autorités la stabilisation se
confirme
le ministère de la santé explique que la
tendance est favorable mais il ne faut
pas conservé de tels chiffres at il
déclaré percy dans 14 régions du pays la
tendance est à la baisse ou à la
stabilisation dans d'autres le nombre de
cas de kobe 19 continue d'augmenter
l'espagne continue d'avoir 500 cas pour
100000 habitants
alors même si la situation est
compliquée le gouvernement se montre
rassurant puisque le pic de transmission
de la seconde vague est bel et bien
passé le gouvernement et même optimiste
et dans les hôpitaux également je vous
propose d'écouter le chef d'unité
qu'ovide d'un grand hôpital barcelonais
nous avons commencé à remarquer une
certaine diminution des hospitalisations
plus le fait qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
guérison nous avons finalement pu éviter
d'ouvrir un quatrième étage qu'ovide ça
c'est un premier signe que la courbe
descendante de la seconde vague comment
ça se remarque est aussi dans les
hôpitaux au niveau de la population
les chiffres montrent que la courbe
commence à diminuer en nombre de
contaminations et en termes de
propagation de l'épidémie
et nous dans les hôpitaux
nous avons commencé à le remarquer au
cours des derniers jours
nous aimerions maintenant que cette
tendance se consolide pour maintenir
cette stabilité
l'espagne durcit les conditions d'entrée
sur son territoire par voie aérienne et
maritime
les voyageurs provenant de pays à
risques devront présenter un résultat de
test pcr négatifs et la france ont fait
partie placée avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du 13 novembre
cinq ans après les attentats la menace
terroriste est remonté à son niveau
maximal alors que la france a fait face
à une série d' attaques sur son
territoire depuis plusieurs mois puis
direction hong kong avec un parlement
aux tiers vide
seuls les parlementaires favorables à
pékin continue de siéger
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qui va là bas c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation il faut que
nous reprenions la place dans le cerveau
des enfants et de la jeunesse
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
on parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont eu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles
s'esquisse les figures du monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre 21h30 heure de
paris il y a cinq ans paris vivait une
nuit d'effroi des attentats dialyse du
13 novembre faisait 130 morts et 350
blessés
c'est l'attaqué la plus meurtrière
jamais commise sur le sol français
alors cinq ans après où on est la menace
terroriste
éléments de réponse avec estelle farges
nice conflans sainte honorine paris ces
trois villes ont été le théâtre
d'attentats depuis le début de l'automne
des attaques survenues quelques semaines
avant la commémoration qui marque les
cinq ans des attentats du 13 novembre
dans un contexte de crise sanitaire
la menace terroriste a parfois pu se
faire oublier mais elle est bel et bien
là c'est en tout cas ce qu'a confié
cette source sécuritaire à nos confrères
de la fp on a pu avoir l'impression que
la menace était passé au deuxième plan
parce que d'autres problématiques ont
émergé les gilet jaune le coc vide mais
en réalité les chiffres montrent bien
qu'elle est restée élevée depuis 2015
en cinq ans 20 attentats ont été commis
sur le sol français
19 ont échoué et 61 ont été déjoués les
trois attaques survenues à récemment ont
poussé le gouvernement à porter le plan
vigipirate à son niveau maximal urgence
attentes à une réévaluation à qui a
aussi été décidé en raison de la
conjonction de plusieurs facteurs
dans le contexte de république à sion
des caricatures de mahomet par charlie
hebdo le 2 septembre 2020 la france et
pour la première fois depuis les
attentats de janvier 2015 l'objet de
trois attaques terroristes en moins d'un
mois le 25 septembre 2020 à paris le 16
octobre 2020 à eragny et le 29 octobre
2020 à nice compte tenu des
circonstances
le premier ministre a décidé d'élever le
niveau vigipirate à son niveau urgence
attentat sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
une menace qui n'est pas propre à la
france l'attentât du 2 novembre dernier
deviennent perpétré par un sympathisant
de dèche démontre que l'ensemble des
pays européens peuvent être touchées
emmanuel macron à d'ailleurs appelé
ensemble des chefs d'état de l'ue eux à
trouver une réponse coordonnée et rapide
à la menace terroriste
il a aussi plaidé pour un renforcement
de la sécurité en europe dans l'hexagone
plusieurs textes en lien avec le sujet
sont dans les tuyaux
le projet de loi contre le séparatisme
islamiste devrait être présenté en
conseil des ministres le 9 décembre
prochain et une nouvelle loi pour le
renseignement devrait être présenté pour
l'été 2021 et pour en parler nous sommes
avec samia maktouf avocat de familles de
victimes du 13 novembre au soir m merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france tout d'abord une question sur les
familles des victimes dans ce contexte
particulier comment se porte-t-elle on
sait que le procès était suspendue dans
quel état d'esprit sont l écouter les
familles les victimes les survivants
sont en dedans effectivement une
situation à la fois d'attentes de
d'interrogation il faut pas oublier
l'environnement que la france a connu
depuis l'ouverture de ce procès et
depuis quelques mois
et tous ces événements tous ces
attentats toutes ces menaces font que
ces victimes sont encore plus
vulnérables
rappelant que les traumatismes ses
blessures ces douleurs n'ont pas pu se
cicatriser encore pour ce qui est des
attentats dans le le procès cinq longues
années après ne s'est pas encore tenu
donc c'est une situation d'attenté avec
une fragilité et avec un lourd
traumatisme et de nour de douleur et de
lourdes ses caprices
on imagine justement une douleur des
cicatrices qui se rouvrent quand on
annonce d'autres attentats en france
comment le vivent ten cela doit être
extrêmement compliqué pour l écouter
très très mal très mal je peux vous dire
que j'ai des certaines victimes que je
suis depuis
5e année certaines se trouvent mal j'ai
même une une victime un client qui a dû
être hospitalisé d'urgence tant le
traumatisme et le l'attentât notamment
pour parler de cette victime il s'agit
du vigile dam des vigiles du stade de
france que je suis qui a dû être
internée
du fait de ce show qui du fait de tout
ce que ça pu impacter c'est que ces
attentats ont pu intenter enfin refaire
vivre chez lui comme douleur comment
s'explique-t-elle sesseli team ces
attaques cette alerte terroriste très
élevé en france est-ce qu'elles ont
veulent au gouvernement est ce qu'elles
ont veulent l'idéologie de ces
islamistes quel est leur état d'esprit
là dessus
écoutez ces victimes sont d'abord dans
une situation de deux de tristesse de
d'attentes latente d'une vérité la tente
de savoir comment comment ils ont pu
perdre leurs proches leurs fils leurs
hommes leurs frères leurs maris donc
c'est pas ton de la colère que la tante
de d'une vérité la tante d'une
explication comme en a tant fait pour ne
pas éviter de ne pas avoir évité ce ce
drame et cet attentat
donc la colère et les ailes et vient sur
un second plan mais le premier plan
c'est comment leur chair leur enfant en
leurs proches ont-ils pu connaître la
vie ils ont ils sont dans la tente de
n'importe quel détail qui a était à
l'occasion de cette mort terrible
ont-ils souffert avant de mourir ont-ils
dit à moussa v ils sont à la recherche
de du moindre détail pour comprendre les
circonstances de la mort de leurs
proches
on a vu récemment ces images en jet
privé des terroristes denis sera menée
pour être soigné patate à paris lyon
ça a choqué vous c'est quoi votre regard
d'avocate il fallait le ramener dans ces
conditions pour le soigner pour
peut-être justement avoir un procès de
façon à ce que les victimes puissent
comprendre ce qui s'est passé c'est ce
genre de buts que l'on poursuit quand on
arrête un terroriste vous savez les
familles de victimes permettez-moi de le
dire haut et fort ne sont liés dans une
situation ni un état d'esprit de
vengeance ou de revanche
ils sont dans une attente de la vérité
savait quand on a perdu ce qu'on a de
plus cher
on n'est pas dans des débats
questionnement de comment
et dans quelles conditions dans quelles
circonstances
ramener un terroriste ou lefebvre
rapatriés nous sommes voyez vous madame
la différence entre notre état de droit
et la l'état de d'endoctrinement et de
l'anarchie situation à laquelle ces
terroristes veulent arriver
et bien moi en tout cas de ce que je
vois de des clients que je suis des
victimes du terrorisme que je suis ils
sont dangereux dans la tente de voir les
responsables quel que soit le niveau de
leurs responsabilités que ça soit ceux
qui ont financé ce qu'ils ont à armer
ceux qui ont logé ce qui en louer des
voitures se cliente endoctrinés saut ce
qui est à l'origine de l'armement de ces
personnes il faut savoir il faut les
arrêter
il faut qu'il réponde il faut qu'il
réponde à la justice c'est un détail de
métaux
pour en revenir justement aux attentats
d'il ya cinq ans une figure importante
s'adapter ce thème va comparaître en
janvier 2021 est ce que ces familles
attendent beaucoup de réponses de lui on
sait qu'il n'a pas du tout voulu parler
ses avocats lorsqu'il était incarcéré
est ce qu'on peut en attendre beaucoup
est ce qu'il n'ya pas peut-être de la
frustration et de la déception à la clé
écoutez laissez moi vous dire qu'une
instruction a été menée pendant cinq
longues années des magistrats
instructeurs français omlt manier et
instruit de manière remarquable les
attentats pour permettre à la vérité
d'éclater
aujourd'hui l'instruction qui vient
d'être clôturée a été menée sans
l'intervention de du terroriste salle
abdeslam c'est grâce à l'instruction
grâce à à tous tout le travail qui a été
fait par le pôle antiterroriste de paris
que
cette instruction a été menée à bien et
achevés à temps
est ce que nous sommes en situation
d'attendre quelque chose de sale arabe
de cela je pense que là la preuve nous a
été apportée sur sa stratégie de défense
qui est celle du mutisme de celle de ne
pas coopérer
malgré ses promesses mais qu'attend que
peut-on attendre dalle terroristes il
est dans le mensonge
il est dans la manipulation dans la
taqiyya aujourd'hui mais les victimes
en tout cas celle que je représente
attendent beaucoup de l'instruction
qu'elle était menée des moyens
gigantesques qui ont été mis à la
disposition du pôle antiterroriste pour
que la vérité éclate et que pour la
condamnation soit à la hauteur de ce que
ses victimes
en dix ans de endurcir et vivre pendant
ces cinq longues années et qui continue
évidemment à à endurer cela ma dernière
question il restait donc judiciaire dont
on vient de parler l'aspect aussi
politique avait un mini sommet hier
consacrée à la lutte contre le
terrorisme à l'échelle européenne on
appelle toujours voilà l'unification etc
on se demande toujours pourquoi les
choses n'ont pas été faites avant vous
attendez vous beaucoup en tant
qu'avocate spécialisée dans le
terrorisme de ce type de sommet on va
assez vite selon vous bah écoutez c'est
important qu'ils aient des sceaux mais
parce que je crois qu'on a mis beaucoup
de temps avant de comprendre que le
terrorisme ne peut pas être menée par un
seul état le terrorisme poursuivi par
ses théories c'est un terrorisme
planétaire et si les états ne se ne sut
ne met pas la main dans la main pour
lutter contre ce terrorisme on n'y
arrivera pas sachant que le risque zéro
n'existe pas et que plus on on s'unit
pour échanger des renseignements pour
coopérer en matière de renseignement au
niveau européen et au delà même de
l'europe
c'est ainsi qu'on pourra efficacement
lutter contre le terrorisme
oui j'espère que ce mini sommet
permettra ne serait-ce que les changes
et la coopération entre les différents
états l' échange d informations qu on
les terroristes concernant toutes les
personnes radicaliser non encore passés
à une action des personnes fichées des
personnes qui ne sont pas dans les
radars des renseignements des mini
sommet comme ça pourrait beaucoup
apporter
merci s'amener avec tours avocate de
familles de victimes du 13 novembre
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france perd c'est beau et on en vient
justement cette visite de gérald
darmanin à moscou le ministre de
l'intérieur et son homologue russe
vladimir kolokoltsev ont discuté des
principaux aspects de la coopération
franco russe en matière de protection de
l'ordre public notamment dans le domaine
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
une visite qui fait suite à l'attentât
contre samuel pâtit le mois dernier
l'assaillant avait été déchu de la
nationalité russe pour la coopération
interministérielle
tout porte à croire que son évolution
sera positive d'autant plus qu'on
constate l'apparition d'un nouveau volet
des relations interétatiques inspiré par
le dialogue entre nos présidents
président bientôt mouvements sociaux là
c'est en tout cas la russie est prête à
une coopération ouverte et mutuellement
bénéfique parce que le terrorisme et
l'extrémisme constitue un mal auquel la
russie fait face depuis longtemps et et
contre lequel nous luttons ardemment
nous sommes prêts à un échange
d'expériences et nous le voyons aucun
obstacle au renforcement de cette
coopération
le parlement de hong kong au tiers vides
seules les parlementaires favorables à
pékin continue de siéger hier l'ensemble
des députés anti gouvernementaux du
conseil législatif ont annoncé leur
démission en raison du renvoi de quatre
de leurs collègues sur une décision de
pékin ces élus était considérée comme
étant une menace pour la sécurité
nationale
l'union européenne appelle pékin revenir
sur sa décision un sujet signé cyrielle
benavides bulbul ans s'est unie et main
dans la main que les députés anti
gouvernementaux ont présenté leur
démission
il quitte le parlement hong kong et par
solidarité à la suite du renvoi de
quatre élus en application d'une mesure
adoptée par pékin il s'agit d'un acte
bien réelle de pékin il pense à sonner
le glas de la lutte pour la démocratie à
hong kong
parce qu'il pense qu'à partir de
maintenant toute personne qu'il trouve
politiquement incorrect ou anti
patriotique qui n'aiment tout simplement
pas voir pourraient être évincés par
tous les moyens d éviction qui s'appuie
sur la loi de sécurité nationale entré
en vigueur début juillet
le texte autorise les autorités locales
à révoquer tout député considérés comme
représentant une menace pour la sécurité
nationale
des mesures soutenues par la chef de
l'exécutif hongkongais alvin young
dennis cooke coca qui est kenneth longue
perdre immédiatement leurs qualités de
législateurs cette décision du comité
permanent de l'assemblée nationale
populaire et constitutionnelles légales
et
nabeul elle est nécessaire et en
adéquation avec la loi fondamentale
les élections législatives du 6
septembre 2020 ayant été reporté en
raison de l'épidémie de coronavirus
elles auront finalement lieu le 5
septembre 2021
cette démission en basse de l'opposition
laissent donc le conseil législatif aux
mains des députés pro pékin réaction des
etats-unis de l'union européenne qui
critiquait l'éviction des parlementaires
de son côté pékin dénonce une ingérence
étrangère
les actions récentes de pékin
disqualifiant les législateurs
pro-démocratie du conseil législatif de
hong kong ne laisse aucun doute sur le
fait que le parti communiste chinois a
violé de manière flagrante ses
engagements internationaux
nous appelons les autorités de pékin et
le gouvernement de hong kong à revenir
immédiatement sur leur décision et
appelons à la réintégration immédiate
des députés
les pays étrangers n'ont aucun droit de
faire des remarques irresponsables dans
le but de se gérer et pour en parler
nous sommes avec un jean vincent brisset
directeur de recherche à l'iris institut
de relations internationales et
stratégiques spécialiste de la chine
bonsoir jean vincent brisset merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
4 députés vent c'est donc à de trop un
parlement sans pause sans opposition au
parlement fantoche pour ainsi dire c'est
que dans la ligne de ce que fait pékin
maintenant depuis deux ou trois ans de
manière continue vouloir absolument
faire disparaître toute trace
d'opposition et venir le système
totalement propre et yonne alors que
pékin s'était engagé à donner 50 ans de
transition à partir de 1999 donc pékin a
eu les engagements pour la transition et
pékin en train de violer ces engagements
de manière extrêmement claire est ce
qu'on la démission des autres collègues
était la bonne stratégie
finalement selon vous il n'y a plus
beaucoup de stratégie dans la mesure où
carrie la meule à la patronne de
l'exécutif hongkongais qui est une
créature de pékin a annoncé très
clairement qu'elle préférait avoir un
parlement qui ne votent plus du tout
plutôt qu'un parlement avec lequel il
faut discuter
les députés qui ont démissionné de toute
façon on n'avait plus de possibilités
d'agir à part voté contre mais ils
étaient minoritaires
quelle sera la conséquence alors les
conséquences si vous voulez il n'y a pas
beaucoup de possibilités sur le plan
politique de faire quelque chose par
contre hong kong était une quelque chose
qu'ils savaient beaucoup à la chine
c'était un sas de décompression entre
des exportations qui sont pas totalement
acceptable par tout le monde et des
exportations qui est après passé par
hong kong devenait acceptable s'il ya la
place financière de hong kong aussi il y
avait une importance énorme si la
communauté internationale applique
vraiment des sanctions hong kong ne
pourra plus servir de plaque tournante
des exportations et qu'on va perdre sa
place de financières au niveau mondial
et il ça va coûter quand même
relativement cher à à la chine mais la
chine année choix qui sont pas
totalement rationnelle sur le plan
économique et les seules sanctions
possibles sont économiques sinon ce sont
les états unis qui propose des des
sanctions l'union européenne s'est
contenté sauf erreur de ma part de
demander la réintégration immédiate de
ces députés les etats-unis sont dans la
bonne stratégie justement pour tenter
d'infléchir les choses hong kong
alors on sait pas si la stratégie
américaine est la bonne anse et que en
fait il semblerait que le futur
président américain et le président
actuel soit tous les deux d'accord sur
des stratégies relativement dure
vis-à-vis de pékin et listrac la
stratégie européenne on peut pas
qualifier sa stratégie sont des discours
pour le moment il n'y a pas d'action
donc c'est pas une stratégie la loi sur
la sécurité nationale elle est sans
limite dans ce contexte qu'est ce que la
contestation pourra-t-elle encore
s'exprimer en compte selon vous alors là
aussi
c'est difficile parce que cette loi
effectivement permet toutes les actions
on est dans une loi qui est totalement
dictatorial et qui permet toutes les
répressions sans aucune limitation
quel que soit le motif il ya pas besoin
de prouver quoi que ce soit je suis
déclaré que untel ou untel adea
fonctionnement qui n'est pas correct
donc ça ça ne peut que continuer dans ce
sens là et la contestation
c'est la contestation les gens vont
voter avec leurs pieds sans doute ce
qu'ils peuvent quitter hong kong vont
quitter hong kong et hong kong de telle
qu'on l'a connue va petit à petit
s'étioler je pense comme comme tanger
s'est étiolée il ya 70 ans et on
s'éloigne en tout cas de plus en plus du
principe un pays deux systèmes
jusqu'où selon vous ce sera ma dernière
question en bleu on va être très
rapidement dans un pays un système et le
système qui avait été premier sur
laquelle la chine populaire s'était
engagé pour 1999 va disparaître sont a
priori il n'y a pas grand chose pour
protestation en tout cas pas grand chose
en europe
merci beaucoup jean vincent brisset
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques spécialiste de la chine
merci à vous et c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve dans quelques
instants à 22 heures précises pour faire
un point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]